this is Jocko podcast number 174 with
echo Charles and me Jocko Willing good
evening echo good evening
so I was the commander of the training
detachment which runs the tactical kind
of advanced training for the West Coast
SEAL Teams and when I was in that
position one of the things that you have
to do when you're in a leadership
position is you have to give evaluations
for everyone that works for you they
have to basically write down and
evaluate how good they are and how well
they do their job this is normal for
everyone in the Navy and everyone the
military really and in the Navy it's a
5.0 system that you're getting graded on
so 5.0 is the best and 1.0 is the worst
I don't know if you can go lower than
that you probably can but there and
there are rules about how many people
you can put at the top you have to four
it's called forced ranking if you've
heard of that forced ranking means you
have to actually rank everyone so fee of
10 people working for you you have to
rank this is my number one guy this
mentor but you got all the way down
through number 10 and so what you cannot
do is you can't just say hey everyone's
great everyone's a 5.0 that's that's
you're not allowed to do that and
believe it or not that's what people
would do most people would just they
have to evaluate someone guess what they
say hey you're great every you do
everything great and you wouldn't think
that the military right the military
would have a hard time telling people
like hey here's some areas where you
need to improve you wouldn't think that
the military especially like the SEAL
Teams you know the big tough seal he's
gonna have a hard time telling some
someone hey this is where your
performances could be better right but
actually no one likes having those hard
conversations I should say just about no
one likes having those hard
conversations in in fact this is
completely evident in the fact that
there was an old evaluation system when
I first got into the Navy and there you
didn't have to force rank you could just
make everyone perfect basically on paper
and that's actually what happened that
system was a 4.0 system so it was a 4.0
was the highest that you could get
mm-hmm and everyone was a 4.0 guy
everyone got 4.0 in everything hmm
and actually have to take that back and
I think I might have talked about this
before but my first evaluation that I
got at a SEAL team when I wasn't even in
a platoon yet but I was going through
the initial training that you used to do
to SEAL team when you got to the SEAL
team you did something called stt which
was stood for SEAL tactical training in
it it basically taught you the little
bit more advanced skills than you
learned in buds and I got a 4.0 and
everything but I actually got a 3.8 in a
category called human relations and I
was I guess you know I talked to my
friends though we got 4.0 on everything
and everyone got for point of except for
me yeah I got the 3.8 and so then you're
supposed to get a counseling right from
and the officer that had written my the
officer that had written my evaluation
and given me all 4.0 4.0 and tactics 4.0
and s 4.0 and the other thing and then a
3.8 in human relations and he had to
counsel me because that's what you have
to do you have to go through and make
sure that no one objects and he he
looked at me and he said you know I give
you a 3.8 in you know in human relations
because well because I think you're a
little too hard on people that are that
are unsatisfied in that you know because
I that time I wasn't really playing the
game you know I kind of was thinking to
myself yeah I that's right you know if
you're unsatisfied
so that was kind of funny but you know
after that
dragged out into a Silpat oon then all
you know everything was 4.0 all the time
and again I'm not bragging at all about
that because every single guy we all had
four point oohs he crossed the board on
everything and everyone was the best
seal on the SEAL Teams ever in the
history of ever
that's what it was like and everyone was
that's just this is the way it was
everyone's the best so the Navy realized
this basically the Navy realized that
all the leaders were cowards and when it
came to telling the truth to the troops
about where they stood and where they
can improve
so they made they made a change they
made this drastic change to the
evaluation and they changed this thing
called forced ranking where you meet
whatever there was percentages on how
many people could be ranked at the
highest level like it was like 10% of
your people can be ranked at the highest
level and then 20% of the next tier and
it went on down the line you didn't
actually have to rank someone as bad but
you couldn't rank a bunch of people at
the top and it was it actually made it
made a big difference all of a sudden
because now all of a sudden you had to
if you were at a leadership position you
had to give your some of your people
some lower rankings and you actually had
to figure out who is better and
[Music]
eventually what they did is again people
not wanting to have hard conversations
eventually what they did is because how
you advance in the Navy is based on your
evaluations which is what we're talking
about but it's also based on how much
time you have in grade so you can't if
you make if you're an e4 you can't make
a five for three years or there's some
some random number like you cannot make
e5 for three years and so what they
started doing is just ranking you based
on how long you were there for and so
that's that's what they started doing so
basically it didn't really help because
you still ended up just saying oh well
you know you're just new and that's why
you didn't get promoted well I didn't
really understand that when the first
when the very first of the forced
ranking evaluations came out I had just
made e5 and because I just maybe five I
got rang
at the bottom of the e fives in my
platoon mm-hmm and like I said at this
time I wasn't really playing the game
really fully so I was kind of went to my
chief and my and my lieutenant with hey
why am i why am i at the bottom well how
how can I be the lowest ranking of the e
fives cuz that's just wrong what about
this guy here you know what about this
guy over here you tell me that this guy
is is doing a better job than I am cuz I
was working really hard and doing a good
job and they didn't disagree with me
mm-hmm what they said is like look yes
Jaco you're you're definitely doing a
better job than that guy and that guy
but here's the deal they're up for
promotion and you're not and when you're
up for promotion you'll be at the top
when it's your turn mm-hmm and again I
wasn't really playing the game so I said
oh okay
you know I get it why don't you just
tell me that we're communists is what it
was what's going on there and you know
they're no we're not communists it's
just you know this is just the way that
the system works okay so what you're
telling is this is a communist system is
what is what's happening thanks comrade
of course they did their best to explain
it to me and I didn't really listen
because like I said don't wasn't really
playing the game at this time was he
young you know II five getting after it
but eventually it was me that was
evaluating people and force ranking them
and then it was me that was explaining
the rules of why people got ranked where
they got ranked and why I gave him the
greats that I gave him and of course I
did this a bunch from when I was an
assistant platoon commander and a
platoon commander and at asking the
commander so I had done this a bunch and
now I was the officer in charge of the
training attachment and I had one of the
guys that didn't like where he got
ranked he was he he didn't like it he
thought he deserved higher and he
thought he deserved a bunch of 5os that
the highest possible grade and you know
maybe not on all the criteria but on
some of them and he actually requested
an office call with me meaning he wanted
to come and talk to me which was kind of
weird because at this time
people literally would just walk in my
office all the time and you know say hey
what's up I got it you know they've
talked to me about something
I was super casual about people coming
to see me even no no factor right so
when this guy went and actually
organized an official meeting with me I
was you know I was totally cool with it
but it was weird and he came in and he
had his evaluation with him and he put
it on my desk and you know he said
something along the lines of you know I
got ranked in the middle of the pack and
how did this happen and I should be at
the top or at least I should be near it
and I should have five O's and in you
know this category in that coder Guri in
this other category and the guy himself
he wasn't a slacker by any stretch of
imagination he was but goods really
solid steel
he wasn't like an over the top
outstanding front-runner but he was
really really solid which you are only
allowed to have a very small number of
guys that you're ranking as fun runners
and he wasn't there and you know I was I
was better at this point at playing the
game you know up and down the chain of
command and so what I did is I sat there
and I listened to him and I listened to
his perspective and as I was doing that
as I was listening this guy and I was
thinking myself you know this guy's a
hard-working seal he thinks he should
have higher grades across the board he
thinks he should be a top ranked guy
with 5.0 's and as I'm sitting there
listening to him I'm thinking why does
he actually think that why does he think
that what is going on in his head that
he thinks that he should be a 5.0 then
of course I'm thinking myself this is
somehow my fault this is gonna be my
fault because I'm the leader and I have
a guy I have a guy that's concerned
enough about his rankings that he's in
here talking to me he actually set an
appointment to come and talk to me about
this so obviously I had not done a good
job at this point of explaining things
to him and if I'm if I'm if he doesn't
get it obviously there's gonna be more
people that that think the same way then
you know he's not the only one when
someone comes to you the problem they're
not the only one so
that's what I'm thinking and I'm um I'm
thinking that he's thinking he's a 5.0
that's what he's thinking he's thinking
he's a 5.0 and he's not and he thinks he
should be and then I'm trying to figure
out I'm thinking to myself okay how do I
explain to him where he is missing the
mark how can I explain to him that he's
not quite a 5.0 because 5.0 is
outstanding and then the answer kind of
jumped out at me the answer was the
evaluation form itself that's that's
what it was because the evaluation form
itself actually gives the definition of
what a 5.0 sailor is what a 5.0 liter is
and really when you break it down to
what a 5.0 human being is the evaluation
actually spells it out in plain English
so I picked up the evaluation form that
he had brought in and I started to read
chunks of it to him so the first little
chunk that I read to read to him was a
section called professional knowledge
and and if you are a 5.0 in professional
knowledge it gives you a list of what
you are and here's what it says if
you're a 5 point on professional
knowledge this is what it says
recognized expert sought out by all four
technical knowledge uses knowledge to
solve complex technical problems meets
advancement requirements early and with
distinction so you know I looked at him
and said okay recognized expert are you
a recognized expert does how often are
you getting called by the East Coast or
by the SEAL team to help them solve a
problem the answer was he's not he's a
good solid guy really good instructor
he's not a he's not a recognized expert
and he knew it
and then I read the the 3.0 which is a
middle grade like hey this is your
average situation I said it maybe this
is you I said listen strong working
knowledge of raiding specialty and job
reliably applies knowledge to accomplish
tasks meets advancement requirements on
time this is a solid human being right
this is a solid that's us that's a 3.0
right there hmm and again as I'm reading
to this this guy yeah he had strong
working knowledge for sure he was
applying that knowledge to his job for
sure
he was doing that so that's cool that's
3.0 what about quality of work another
section quality work here's 5.0 for
quality of work needs no supervision
always produces exceptional work no
rework required maximizes resources so
needs no resources let's think about
that I mean this guy was working in
another department he was definitely
being managed and then always produces
exceptional work again this is as good
you can't get any better than
exceptional hmm so I said is that you do
you not need any supervision and he knew
I mean I know I worked in the
department's I know what's going on he's
not gonna you can't lie to me and I said
how about this needs little supervision
produces quality work few errors use his
resources efficiently you know what that
is that's 3.0 I actually gave you a 4.0
so I'm wearing between those two I'm
actually being kind of generous what do
you think mm-hmm how about military
bearing and character well let's see
what that looks like here's what here's
what here's what that definition for
military bearing and character is US
Navy
5.0 evaluation exemplary personal
appearance model of conduct conduct on
and off duty a leader in physical
readiness exemplifies Navy core values
honor courage commitment now
this guy's sitting in my office he's in
sloppy PT gear his hair is a little bit
long and he's not he's not one of these
super stud seals that's an awesome
physical shape he's kind of a guy that
like to party a bit and he was a
hard-working seal a great guy but I'm
saying he wasn't exactly a model of
conduct on and off duty think about what
that means a model of conduct so that's
five point all right then I said listen
let me tell you what I tell him let me
tell you what 3.0 is excellent personal
appearance excellent conduct
conscientiously complies with
regulations complies with physical
readiness program lives up to Navy core
values honor courage commitment but that
to me you know you're a pretty squared
away guy but look how'd you do on that
last PT test mm-hmm right because you
you didn't knock it out of the park I
know that right so you are you telling
him yes you're reading me I'm doing what
we're doing right here I'm straight-up
reading them to him because because it
was it's really obvious yeah that these
standards are very very high and you
know that also here's the bottom of the
barrel okay this is 1.0 1.0 four four
values or four military bearing and
character this is 1.0 consistently
unsatisfactory appearance poor
self-control conduct resulting in
disciplinary action unable to meet one
or more physical readiness requirements
fails to live up to one or more Navy
core values honor courage commitment so
so this guy clearly is not a 1-point oh
that's it that's a you know that's
a that's a bad sailor mmm but this guy's
solid he's in the middle I think I had
him with a four point I said I are we
good with a four Oh mm-hmm
or are you gonna tell me that you
crushed that you were the leader of the
pack on the last PT test that we did you
know what will you tell me were you the
fru-u-- you the 5.0 no couldn't honestly
say it and by now he kind of he kind of
got the message that he's not one point
no but he definitely wasn't a 5.0 either
and and clearly what I realize is he
never actually read through what those
standards
were and clearly that was my fault for
not making sure that this guy and the
rest of the people at my command
understood what the grading criteria was
and I started to try and do that I
started to realize that the the grading
criteria was actually solid it was a
good guide to being a really good seal a
really good sailor a really good person
and as you read through some of these
5.0 qualities here's the one for command
organizational climate / equal
opportunity so if you're this is you're
if you're a five-o in this category
measurably contributes to the Navy's
increased retention and reduced
attrition objective proactive leader
exemplary mentor involved in suborn it's
personal development leading to
professional growth and sustained
commitment initiates support programs
for military civilian and families to
achieve exceptional command and
organizational climate the model of
achievement develops unit cohesion by
valuing differences as strengths so
let's think about that that's that's a
massive who's gonna get five-o in that
you know SEAL Teams not too many people
because in the SEAL Teams who's
initiating support programs means you're
actively starting a program to help
support right there's not a lot of guys
they're gonna hit 5.0 and that's the way
it should be
here's what 5.0 looks like for personal
job accomplishment and initiative
energetic self-starter completes tasks
or qualifications early far better than
expected so you're not just doing you're
doing it early and it's still even
better than everyone else plans and
prioritizes wisely and with exceptional
foresight seeks extra responsibilities
and takes on the hardest jobs that's 5.0
here's the here's the five bullet point
ofer teamwork team builder inspires
cooperation in progress focuses goals
and techniques for teams the best at
accepting and offering team direction
that's a team player that's teamwork and
here's here's the here's how you get a
5.0 in leadership now think about this
you think you're a good seal you think
you're a good sailor and you think I'm
I'm a good leader right here's what you
have to do to get a 5.0 inspiring
motivator and trainer subordinates reach
highest level of growth and development
so now uh since I'm about you anymore
this is about you being a leader and you
not just what you do but what your
subordinates have to reach the highest
level of growth and development
it goes on superb organizer great
foresight develops process improvements
in efficiencies leadership achievements
leadership achievement dramatically
further command mission and vision so
what you do as a leader dramatically
furthers the mission persevere through
the toughest challenges and inspires
other others exceptional communicator
how many people do you know that are
exceptional communicators there's not a
lot of people that are exceptional
commuters it that's a hard thing that's
not only being born with some
communication skills it's actively
working and honing those skills through
your lifetime before someone tells you
you're an exceptional communicator hmm
make subordinate safety conscience
maintains top safety record constantly
improves the personal and professional
lives of others so this is this is
barely even about you anymore it's how
well how well does your team do so
you've got to be a hundred percent
squared away if you're gonna get a 5.0
in leadership that's just the way it is
and and like I said you're not just
getting judged on your success but on
the success not just of the mission but
of the actual individual people that
work for you hmm
and so this this granular look at these
descriptions kind of changed this guy's
perspective and now he actually saw what
he was supposed to be doing and he
actually knew what he was aiming at and
he didn't know that before and you know
whose fault it is that he didn't know
that it's my fault because I'm the guy
that's in charge and I thought everyone
knew or I thought at least everyone was
aiming as high as they possibly good at
everything but that's actually not Eve
it's naive
a couple reasons not only is not
everyone aiming to be the best they can
know some people don't care about some
things but sometimes people don't
actually understand what it is that
they're supposed to be aiming at they
don't understand what the metric is how
they're being measured and clearly you
have to have something to aim at and if
you don't have anything to aim at then
you're never gonna get anywhere you're
never gonna you're never gonna hit the
target that's you're not aiming at you
have to aim at the target to hit it you
have to know what you are trying to be
or you won't be that and the Navy I
think with this evaluation form does a
decent job if you kind of can take a
step back and one problems with the with
the Navy evaluation system and all the
evaluation systems in the military is
they're very administrative it's it
turns into much more of a paperwork
drill than it is an actual an actual
attempt to make people improve
themselves right it's there but people
are gonna fall on this is where I fell
out cool I'm up for promotion Co I'm at
they don't read it yeah right they don't
actually it's not it's not a true
counseling up to the objective isn't to
really truly improve those people that's
one of the problems with this mmm
with the with the counseling system
inside the Navy and it happens in the
other branch as well but but if you read
that sheet and you kind of take a look
at it
then you realize okay there's some
things that I can aim at now and the
Navy does a decent job of that I'll tell
you the Marine Corps does an even better
job the United States Marine Corps
evaluation system is more detailed and
it's more descriptive and it's more
complete the Navy system then over the
whole Navy evaluation is two pages long
the Marine Corps
theirs is six pages long and one thing
that's interesting about the Marine
Corps you know in in the Navy one they
list ok the Euro 1.0 this is what you're
like as a 1.0 the Marine Corps doesn't
even give descriptions for the low end
of the spectrum they don't even they
don't even exist they're not gonna waste
time describing a loser
Marine they have a
your minimum standard basically but this
is one thing that struck me the the
first time I kind of noticed the Marine
Corps evaluation system because it's
it's an administrative thing so it's not
like I would see it on a regular basis
when I was in Rome adios in the brigade
Tactical Operations Center and I was
probably there for a meeting with the
brigade commander or whatever and was
there for whatever reason and one of the
Marine officers was in there who I knew
and we were kind of talking and he was
filling out one of al uation for one of
his guys and he was on the back page of
his evaluation and I was just you know
being nosy I guess looking at looking at
what it was like looking at what their
system was like comparing it to our
system and as I was looking at the form
on the last page the page he was
actually working on there was a a
graphic representation of of Marines and
of how they rank Marines and it kind of
looked like a Christmas tree so have you
picture a Christmas tree and the whole
Christmas tree is made up of little
Eagle Globe and Anchor switch is the
symbol of the Marine Corps and so
there's a bunch of little Eagle Globe
and Anchor x' and they're all positioned
on this piece of paper and it looks like
a Christmas tree and so the bottom
actually the bottom of this graphic the
bottom of this Christmas tree is just an
empty space there's nothing there and
and that line is represented there's a
little indicator that shows what that
line represents that line represents the
unqualified Marine so there should be no
unqualified Marines in your unit and
then it goes up one level and now you've
just got one single Eagle Globe and
Anchor representing one Marine and and
this this is it looks like the trunk of
the Christmas tree and that that line is
labeled a qualified Marine so now you've
got one guy you know percentage-wise one
person that is simply just a qualified
Marine he's qualified but there's not
there shouldn't be that many of them and
then they go now he picks her Christmas
tree above the trunk now it's a big wide
area and that's where they go to this
next level
has the most it's like the middle third
of the Christmas tree
and that area they labeled that area one
of the many highly qualified
professionals who form the majority of
this grade so the biggest chunk of
people is sort of in the middle third of
this Christmas tree and that's what it
is
hey that's what most of that's where
most of the guys are theirs Holly highly
qualified people they make up the most
of this group of that I'm evaluating and
there they are and then above that third
on this Christmas tree is a now the
Christmas tree is getting smaller right
so now we're getting into a narrow group
in this narrow group is labeled and it's
called so if you're in this group you're
being labeled as one of the few
exceptionally qualified Marines and that
again that's a much smaller number than
that middle group and then you get to
the top of the Christmas tree where
there is a single Eagle Globe and Anchor
representing the very best of this group
and it's up there alone at the pinnacle
of performance and there's a label for
this singular Marine at the top of his
group and the label says the eminently
qualified marine and I remember when I
read that when I read those words the
eminently qualified marine and I thought
to myself that is the ultimate praise
and that's pretty much how the Marine
Corps evaluation ends and it ends in
this epic way because it is it is and I
it's weird to say this it's an epic
document it's an epic epic document and
I want to talk about this document today
and I want to start off by by the way
that the document itself starts off so
this is the Marine Corps fitness report
this is how they grade Marines and it
starts off with the Commandant guidance
so the first thing they get is guidance
from the most senior marine in the
Marine Corps and the Commandant guidance
says the completed Fitness report is the
most important information component in
manpower management it is the primary
means of evaluating a Marines
performance and is the Commandant's
primary tool for the selection of
personnel for promotion augmentation
residents schooling command and duty
assignments therefore the completion of
this report is one of an officer's most
critical responsibilities inherent in
this Duty is the commitment of each
reporting senior and reviewing officer
to ensure the integrity of the system by
giving close attention to accurate
marking and timely reporting every
officer serves a role in the scrupulous
maintenance of this evaluation system
ultimately important to both the
individual and the marine corps
inflationary markings only serve to
dilute the actual value of each report
reviewing officers will not concur with
inflated reports so out of the gate
we're getting put in check do not come
here telling everyone they're great
that's not that's not gonna fly we're
rejecting that out right from the start
now we start the evaluation again this
is set up a little bit similar to the
Navy and they start breaking out what
your performance is based on the first
thing that it's based on is mission
accomplishment and mission
accomplishment they break into two
things the first thing is performance so
here's what it says about performance of
mission accomplished accomplishment
results achieved during the reporting
period how well those duties inherent to
a Marines billet plus all additional
duties form
and informally assigned were carried out
reflects a Marines aptitude competence
and commitment to the unit's success
above personal reward indicators our
time and resource management task
prioritization and tenacity to achieve
positive ends consistently so the low
end it says meets requirements of billet
and additional duties aptitude
commitment and competence meet
expectations results maintain status quo
so that's as I you're doing your job and
then if you're at the high end of the
spectrum results far surpass
expectations recognizes and exploits new
resources creates opportunities emulated
sought-after as an expert with influence
beyond unit impact significant
innovative approaches to problems
produce significant gains in quality and
efficiency if you just take that single
bullet and that's what you try and
achieve you're smoking you're crushing
you I want to I you have someone like
that working for you and you're in
heaven because this guy's gonna make
things happen
next up proficiency demonstrates
technical knowledge and practical skill
in the execution of the Marines overall
duties combines training education and
experience translate skills into actions
which contribute to accomplishing tasks
and missions imparts knowledge to others
think about this one translates skills
and actions that's it that's kind of a
big deal how many people have skills but
they can't translate them into actions
think about that's your life hey you got
some skills but you don't use them you
can't put them anywhere
you can't put them into effect here's
the middle grade for proficiency
demonstrates mastery of all required
skills so if you've mastered your skills
you're still just in the middle
expertise education and experience
consistently enhance mission
accomplishment innovative troubleshooter
and problem solver effectively imparts
skills to suborn 'it's these are the
kind of things with you know that you're
supposed to impart skills to your
subordinates you pay attention to it you
start doing it hmm but you might not
recognize that that's part of your job
that's part of your life here's what it
sounds like if you're an expert true
expert in field knowledge and skills
impact far beyond those of peers
translates broad-based
education and experience into
forward-thinking innovative actions
makes immeasurable impact on mission
accomplishment
peerless teacher selflessly imparts
expertise to subordinates peers and
seniors think about that that is a high
bar that is a high bar you could work
you could work diligently every single
day and fall short of that yeah buzz let
me tell you it's important that you know
that you should be working towards it
hmm next section individual character
isn't that legit when you're gonna grade
someone on their character this is
outstanding yeah this is outstanding how
many people are not thinking about what
their characters how many people are not
actively minding the way that their
actions reflect their character happens
all the time yeah if we were thinking
about if you knew you're getting great
on it maybe you wouldn't take those
those base actions yeah yeah it kind of
goes along with like how you said that
one time like imagine someone's
videotaping either and they're gonna do
the playback it's like man if you go if
you have that in the back of your mind
yeah yeah yeah that's the first step
though because the actual that's the
first step because you might think well
I'm being videoed but this is what I'm
expected to do so you might be doing
something that's not correct
hmm you might be off chart you might be
aiming at the wrong thing hey I'm acting
like a tough guy I want everyone to know
that I'm tough you realize oh that's
actually stupid yeah yeah so you can be
you can have in your mind that I'm gonna
keep my character but you're wrong
because you might be aiming at the wrong
thing yeah so this gives you some pretty
specific things to aim at topic number
one core courage
moral or physical strength to overcome
danger fear difficulty or anxiety
personal acceptance of responsibility
and accountability placing conscience
over competing interests regardless of
consequences conscious overriding
decision to risk bodily harm or death to
accomplish the mission or save others
the will to persevere despite
uncertainty what if you're thinking
about the fact that you're getting
graded on you will to persevere despite
uncertainty you think about that every
day you don't know what your future
holds
but you're gonna persevere regardless
think if you're getting graded on that
every day here's what the bottom end of
the spectrum is demonstrates inner
strength so at the minimum you're
demonstrating inner strength and
acceptance of responsibility
commensurate with the scope of duties
and experience willing to face moral or
physical danger in pursuit of mission
accomplishment so even at the low end of
the spectrum you're still willing to
face danger moral or physical challenges
here's the middle guided by conscience
in all actions proven ability proven
ability to overcome danger fear
difficulty or anxiety exhibits bravery
in the face of adversity uncertainty not
deterred by moral difficult situations
morally difficult situations or has
missed responsibilities how often are
people deterred by difficult situations
daily morally morally difficult
situations here's at the top the top of
this spectrum for courage uncommon
bravery and capacity to overcome
obstacles and inspire others in the face
of moral dilemma or life-threatening
danger now it's not even just about you
you have to actually take it to level
we're inspiring others demonstrated
under the most adverse conditions
selfless always places conscience over
competing interest regardless of
physical or personal consequence
that's that competition we talked about
the competition between oh I'm gonna
take care of myself and I'm gonna take
care of the team I'm gonna take care of
the mission hmm between what's doing
what's right to do instead of what is
easy to do the next section that you
could created on your individual
character is effectiveness under stress
this is just outstanding
because there's not think about this you
don't even see this in business I don't
see this and when people evaluate other
other in the business world but there's
stress in business world is a different
kind of stress but it's stress here's
effectiveness under stress here's what
you're doing
thinking functioning and leading
effectively under conditions of physical
and/or mental pressure maintaining
composure appropriate for the situation
while displaying steady purpose of
action in abling one two it's inspire
others while continuing to lead under
adverse conditions physical and
emotional strength resilience and
endurance are elements low end of the
spectrum exhibits discipline and
stability under pressure judgment and
effective problem solving skills are
evident just low end of the spectrum by
the way how many people do you think do
you know that don't exhibit any
discipline or stability under pressure
right there's all kinds of people
there's all kinds of people and we know
when's the last time you you you didn't
do a good job under pressure
probably this morning it happens right
yeah fully but yeah especially when
you're not thinking about especially
when you're not aimed at the correct
response to pressure you know especially
when you haven't put a standard in your
mind remember when you used to kind of
freak out in jujitsu when you got
claustrophobic right sure yeah right
sure you'd get in application yes sir
yeah usually side control right you
didn't like that yeah the pressure on
the neck the pressure on the chest there
were more circumstances surrounding
those you know scenarios yes mental and
moral problems yeah it would have to be
okay
yes I do remember that yeah at some
point you said to yourself alright I
cannot act that way anymore yeah you
made a you set a bar for yourself yes
sir that's the beginning of solving the
problem yeah that's what I love about
this it's actually setting a bar of when
you're under stress this is how you
gotta act mmm if you're if you're a
little above average for effectiveness
under stress here's where you're at
consistently demonstrates maturity
mental agility and willpower during
periods of adversity provides order to
chaos through the application of
intuition problem-solving skills and
leadership composure reassures other
imagine you're on a team and this is the
average guy hmm this is just so
impressive but my point is unless you
tell your guys what average is they
won't know it yeah they don't understand
it here's the high end so this is when
you look at your troops you say this is
what I want you to do when we come under
massive amounts of stress here's the
model I want you to try and perform as
demonstrates seldom matched presence of
mind under the most demanding
circumstances stabilizes any situation
through the resolute and timely
application of Direction focus and
personal presence now when I was doing
this I was actually only gonna read the
high end mm-hmm when I was thinking
about this but then I realized each one
of these builds and that person at the
high end already has the other two but
there's other elements in there that
aren't mentioned in the high end so you
got to mention me and you assume when
someone's on the high end they got those
obviously they got the lower end things
wrapped up so you got to combine all
these three together the low-grade the
middle grade and the high grade we want
people to show initiative I talk about
this all the time this is the essence of
decentralized command is that people
show initiative here's what they say
about initiative action in the absence
of specific direction seeing what needs
to be done and acting without prompting
hmm
so I'm listening to all these and this
whole thing and at first I was like oh
that's cool that's how the Navy kind of
evaluates people and I'm sure you're
gonna talk about the Marines and stuff
but maybe like the second little part
you started reading I just started
applying it to myself that's what I'm
saying like my life yeah like okay so
you know we're all part of like if you
have a family if you're a the dad or
something right or you're whatever if
you if you're in a family unit you're
part of a team right there and you know
your goals changed from time to time but
you sort of know the goals so I'm like
thinking in my mind every little like
element that you're talking about I'm
like okay let me evaluate myself for
sure with this like how good and you're
right man so a lot of - a lot of times
like okay so performing under um under
stress like there's all these little
things you're going to the beach and
you're trying to make it on the beach we
have a high stress level you see the
kids need their water and they need
their changing clothes you might get
cold they need to Jackie and all the
stuff meanwhile the clock is ticking you
know daylight's August you should want
to miss sunset August um so how are you
gonna perform under that stress you know
and uh I get it well the 43 you're
bringing up this you bring up this and
I'm actually completely making fun of
you for bringing up that stress how
often are you at a public place and you
see a family and they're running later
whatever and you see a leader of the
family mother or father freaking out
losing their composure over the stress
that we are actually joking about yeah
you're a little bit serious I'm joking
about it but you see people lose their
minds because of dumb things oh yeah and
there's a little bit of stress in their
world and they drop the ball they've the
Freak a farm
exactly so my question is do those
people has anyone ever sat them down and
explained to them what the standard is
yes sir and that's my point here yeah
exams people don't even recognize they
don't even know they don't understand
what what the eminently qualified human
being is how they're going to act in
these situations yeah it totally totally
exactly hundred percent right there so
like okay so you know how irid have a
guy who like loses his temper and then
like you say hey you kind of lost it
there and then he goes back to how he
felt like almost like the way he felt
justified oh yeah right
so you just understand here's the thing
Brad look we know you felt like that
you totally demonstrate so you don't
have to explain now yeah you were
feeling this and you behaved the certain
way but in fact I knew that he was being
evaluated on his behavior regardless of
how he feels but he'd be aiming how you
put it that's it that's how it's not
it's not just the grading part it's you
have to know what this standard is
because that guy that might not even
understand hey if I lose my temper its I
think is either I think was JP JP really
took it to heart when he heard me say
losing your temper as a weakness yeah
before that he just didn't you know
because you see other people in your
life is the other team guys you see your
dad you see your uncle and they fly off
the handle and you almost have a respect
for it right
you definitely respect your when your
dad loses your temper you kind of think
wow that's powerful how can I have some
of that power well you just do that
right so it's a learned mechanism and
then eventually you realize or someone
tells you hey when you lose your temper
you're not in control matter of fact
you're not control at all and whatever
made you lose your temper is controlling
you and losing your temper is is a
weakness and so that's the big
difference it's not just hey you're
being graded you're being watched which
is definitely a great mindset to have
but you have to understand what the
parameters are that you're being
measured by that you're being graded on
and that's where this comes into play
the next section I just started with
initiative and we want subordinates to
take initiative but we want everyone to
take initiative right
oh you're kids you want your kids to
take initiative you want people in your
you want everyone to take in this
if I used to say to the young seal you
platoon commanders and tasking
commanders I would say imagine if
everyone in your every one of your fire
team leaders just was doing something
smart they just took initiative and made
it happen
your job becomes so easy because you
enough to control everything everyone's
just making things happen
that's initiative so here's what it says
about initiative action in the absence
of specific direction seeing what needs
to be done and acting without prompting
the instinct to begin a task and
follow-through energetically on one's
own accord
being creative proactive and decisive
transforming opportunity into action so
that's one initiative if you're on the
low end you demonstrate willingness to
take action in the absent of absence of
specific direction acts commensurate
with grade training and experience
that's what we expect of you
a little bit a little bit better in the
middle self-motivated in an action
oriented foresight and energy
consistently transform opportunity into
action develops and pursues creative
initiative solutions or sorry innovative
solutions acts without prompting
self-starter that's what we want and
then here we go the high end highly
motivated and proactive displays
exceptional awareness of surroundings
and environment uncanny ability to
anticipate mission requirements and
quickly formulate original far-reaching
solutions always takes decisive
effective action with definitions like
that it's no wonder there's only one
marine at the top of that Christmas tree
because that is a squared away
individual right there far you know
what's crazy about this having put so
many people through training myself even
though there's only one allotted space
up there there are so many people that
are capable of this kind of behavior
it's way more than one person it's way
more than ten percent if you have people
that understand what the parameters are
and really aim toward you can get a lot
closer than most people would think yeah
and is I mean I obviously I don't
no but it seems like where you're
talking about if they'd like a lot of
people just don't know you know no I
don't know the standard and that you
know they don't know you know they don't
know it's not been made clear to them
yeah the next section leadership and
this is broken if there's a multiple
sections obviously because leadership is
the most important thing on the
battlefield so this is their biggest
section leadership section number one
leading subordinates the inseparable
relationship between leader and lead the
application of leadership principles to
provide direction and motivate
subordinates using authority persuasion
and personality to influence
subordinates to accomplish assigned
tasks sustaining motivation in morale
while maximizing subordinates
performance so there you go that's what
you going to do as leader low end
engaged provides instructions and
directs execution seeks to accomplish
mission in ways that sustain motivation
and morale actions contribute to unit
effectiveness cool so your acceptable
yeah middle ground achieves a highly
effective balance between direction and
delegation we're talking a little
dichotomy effectively tasks subordinates
and clearly delineates extent standards
expected enhances performance through
constructive supervision fosters
motivation and enhances morale builds
and sustains teams that successfully
meet mission requirements encourages
initiative and candor among subordinates
so you can see that the the low end
you're kind of just telling people what
to do a little bit right now you're
starting to ask for feedback you're
starting to build that bond here's the
high end number-one thing for the high
end promotes creativity and energy among
subordinates by striking in the ideal
balance of direction and delegation
achieves highest levels of performance
from subordinates by encouraging
individual initiative that's
decentralized command I'm gonna let you
guys
and that's gonna maximize performance
this is an incredible term engenders
willing subordination loyalty and trust
that allows subordinates to overcome
their perceived limitations willing
subordination when your team actually
wants to follow you personal leadership
fosters highest level of motivation and
morale ensuring mission accomplishment
even in the most difficult circumstances
next section developing subordinates
commitment to train educate and
challenge all Marines regardless of race
religion ethnic background or gender
mentorship cultivating professional and
personal development of subordinates
developing team players and esprit de
corps ability to combine teaching and
coaching creating an atmosphere tolerant
of mistakes in the course of learning
you know here you'll think about that
very often the Marine Corps hey we're
tolerant of mistakes that's how you
learn low end of the spectrum maintains
an environment that allows personal
professional development ensures
subordinates participate in all mandated
development programs middle ground
develops and Institute's
innovative programs so you're
proactively trying to bring up and raise
your subordinate to include PMA which is
professional military education that
emphasize personal and professional
development of subordinates challenges
subordinates to exceed their perceived
potential thereby enhancing unit morale
and effectiveness creates an environment
where all Marines are confident to learn
through trial and error as a mentor
prepares subordinates for increased
responsibilities and duties by the way
this is the number two item under
leadership the first one is leading the
second one is developing your
subordinates here's the top end of the
spectrum widely recognized and and
emulated as a teacher coach and leader
any Marine would desire to serve with
this Marine because they know they will
grow personally and professionally
subordinate and unit performer
far surpasses expected results due to
mentorship and team-building talents
attitude toward subordinate development
is infectious extending beyond the unit
that's bold now you are training your
people so well that other people in
other units are starting to train their
people think about that impact right
there that's how you develop you develop
your subordinates so much that some
other leader in a different company in a
different platoon in a different
battalion says we're gonna start
following that program gonna start
stepping it up yeah
the hats leadership right there section
of a tree setting the example the most
visible facet of leadership how well a
Marine serves as a role model for all
others personal action demonstrates the
highest standards of conduct ethical
behavior fitness and appearance bearing
demeanor and self-discipline are
elements low end maintains Murray corne
standards for appearance of weight and
uniform wear sustains required level of
physical fitness adheres to the tenets
of the Marine Corps values
fine you're accepted middle grade
personal conduct on and off duty
reflects highest Marine Corps standards
of integrity bearing and appearance
character is exceptional actively seeks
self-improvement in wide ranging areas
dedication to duty and professional
example encourage others
self-improvement efforts
that's the middle grade the in the
middle grade you reflect the highest
Marine Corps standards of integrity
bearing in appearance you know what that
means that means there's 24 hours a day
you're in the game that's what that
means
it means you're active actively seeking
self-improvement in wide ranging areas
you're trying to get better everywhere
that's mental ground by the way high
ground
model marine frequently emulated
exemplary conduct behavior and actions
our tone setting an inspiration to
subordinates peers and seniors
remarkable dedication to improving self
and others what are you trying to do to
get better I mean I say that said that
on this podcast since day one we're
trying to get better what are you doing
actually yeah what's what's the activity
because I've known another word you see
here a lot and this is action action
action words into action ideas into
actions
skills into action yeah I was going back
and forth with a guy that I did some
work with for echelon front and I worked
with him quite a few years ago overseas
and we still text back and forth from
time to time and he I said hey because
he was telling me some of the notes he
had taken I said send me some of the
notes one of the notes that he for the
first note he sent me was you can't
think things better it's it's it's a
solid piece of advice because he's one
of these guys that that was a thinker
right a big thinker and I'm all about
thinking you know let's let's develop
our brain it's develop our mind power
let's think about things let's be
thoughtful that's fine but you can't
think things better they're not going to
get better unless you actually apply the
skills skills into action thoughts into
action
next ensuring well-being of subordinates
the genuine interest in the well-being
of Marines enhances subordinates ability
to concentrate focus on mission
accomplishment concern for family
readiness is inherent the importance
placed on welfare of subordinates is
based on the belief that Marines take
care of their own low end of the
spectrum deals confidently with issues
pertinent to subordinate welfare and
recognizes suitable courses of action
that supports subordinates well-being
applies available resources allowing
subordinates to effectively concentrate
on the mission at a minimum you're
absolutely taking care of your people
middle-grade instills and/or reinforces
a sense of responsibility among junior
Marines for themselves and their
subordinates actively fosters the
development of and uses support systems
for subordinates which improve their
ability to contribute to unit mission
accomplishment efforts to enhance
subordinate welfare improve the unit's
ability to accomplish their mission
people don't think about that fact the
the people that are actually
accomplishing the mission are people and
those people aren't ready to perform
because even neglected them mmm you're
not gonna build to accomplish the
mission high-grade
noticeably enhances subordinates
well-being resulting in measurable
increase in unit effectiveness maximizes
unit and base resources to provide
supports with the best support available
proactive approach serves to energize
unit members to take care of their own
thereby correcting potential problems
before they can hinder subordinates
effectiveness
widely recognized for techniques and
policies that produce results and build
morale builds strong family atmosphere
puts motto mission first Marines always
into action boom
last section for leadership
communication skills the efficient
transmission and receipt of thoughts and
ideas that enable an enhanced leadership
equal importance given to listening
speaking writing and critical reading
skills interactive allowing one to
perceive problems and situations provide
concise guidance and expects Express
complex ideas in a form easily
understood by everyone allows
subordinates to ask questions raise
issues and concerns and venture opinions
contributes to a leaders ability to
motivate as well as counsel minimum
skilled and receiving and conveying
information communicates effectively in
performance of duties that's the minimum
above average middle grade clearly
articulates thoughts and ideas verbally
and in writing let's think about that
middle ground do you know how hard it is
for people to clearly articulate
thoughts and ideas verbally and in
writing it is a skill you need to work
on all the time by the way this gets you
a middle grade here yeah communication
in all forms is accurate intelligent
concise and timely those standards
accurate intelligent concise and timely
communicates with clarity and Verve
ensuring understanding of intent or
purpose encourages and considers the
contributions of others high grade here
we go highly developed facility in
verbal communication adept in composing
written documents of the highest quality
combines presence and verbal skills
which indent engender confidence and
achieve understanding irrespective of
setting situation or size of group
addressed displays an intuitive sense of
when and how to listen so read write
speak listen and do it all the time
if you're in a leadership position or
you want to be in one that the the
reading part people ask me what I
learned in college one of the most
important things that I learned in
college was I was an English major this
is why I was an English major by the way
because I recognized when I was at a
SEAL team as a young officer that one of
the most important things I was gonna be
dealing with was communicating with
other humans and I needed to have good
command of the English language and of
reading and of writing the English
language but when I had to decipher
Shakespeare and I took a lot of
Shakespeare and you realize that you
don't know what words mean and you
realize that you don't understand the
sentence construction and you what you
realize is that you have to break them
down and go through them and figure it
out so when I would get the rules of
engagement from up the chain of command
five years later and I didn't understand
them because they were using words I
didn't know I said okay what I need to
do is look these up read it find out
some substitute words make sense of it
look up the definition of what they're
specifically talking about and go from
there
because when you first if you just open
up Shakespeare and you don't understand
something what do you do you say it's
stupid when somebody writes the rules of
engagement and there's words in there
you don't understand if you don't
understand how to parse things apart and
look up definitions and can't be humble
enough to recognize that there's some
things that you don't know well then all
you do is go this is stupid
check
Communications the next thing no one
really probably thinks that this is
gonna be in here for the Marine Corps
the next section you're getting grade on
as graded on as a Marine is intellect
and wisdom they're things to people in
the military is a bunch of knuckle
draggers I think it's all about brawn
but there you go
intellect and wisdom in electing wisdom
professional military education PMA
committed to intellectual growth in ways
beneficial to the marine corps increases
breadth and depth of warfighting and
leadership aptitude resources include
residents schools professional
qualifications and certification
processes non-resident and other
extension courses civilian educational
institutional coursework a personal
reading program that includes but is not
limited to selections from the
combatants reading list participation in
discussion groups and military societies
and involvement in learning through new
technologies you got to get in the game
right there
got to get educated here's low-end
maintains currency and required military
skills and related developments has
completed or is enrolled in appropriate
level of PME for grade and level of
experience recognizes and understands
new and creative approaches to service
issues remains abreast of contemporary
concepts and issues middle grade PMA
outlook expense expands beyond MOS and
required education so you're not even
worried about your own job you've got
that covered now you're going outside of
what your job is
develops and follows a comprehensive
personal program which includes
broadened professional reading and/or
academic coursework advances new
concepts and ideas and here's your high
end dedicated to lifelong learning as a
result of active and continuous efforts
widely recognized as an intellectual
leader
in professionally related topics makes
time for study and takes advantage of
all resources and programs introduces
new and creative approaches to service
issues engages in a broad spectrum of
forums and dialogues so this is never
gonna stop you got to keep feeding your
brain the next thing you're getting
graded on intellect and wisdom
decision-making ability viable and
timely problems solution contributing
elements are judgement and decisiveness
decisions reflect the balance between an
optimal solution and a satisfactory
workable solution that generates tempo
so there's a good dichotomy for you
optimal decision on one side workable
decision that can keep you moving on the
other side you got to balance that
dichotomy decisions are made within the
context of the commander's established
intent and the goal of mission
accomplishment so of course you're
trying to support the commander's intent
anticipation mental agility intuition
and success are inherent this is not the
first time they brought up intuition in
here hmm how do you develop into
intuition experience wisdom reading low
end low end makes sound decisions
leading to mission accomplishment as the
minimum the minimum is to make sound
decisions actively collects and
evaluates information and ways
alternative alternatives to achieve
timely results confidently approaches
problems accepts responsibility for
outcomes middle-grade demonstrates
mental agility effectively prioritizes
and solves multiple complex problems
this prioritize and executes analytical
abilities enhanced by experience
education and intuition anticipates
problems and implements viable long-term
solutions solutions steadfast willing to
make difficult decisions that's a that's
a high bar for middle grade
high-grade widely recognized and
sought-after to resolve the most
critical complex problems seldom matched
analytical and intuitive abilities
accurately foresees unexpected problems
and arrives at well-timed decisions
despite fog and friction completely
compliment approach to all problems
masterfully strikes a balance between
the desire for perfect knowledge and
greater tempo widely recognized to solve
problems
this one though this little line here
accurately foresees unexpected problems
and arrives at well-timed decisions
despite fog and friction has a big ask
right there you got to be in the game
you got to be in the game to get to that
level last thing you're getting great on
on for intellect and wisdom is judgment
the discretionary aspect of
decision-making draws on core values
knowledge and personal experience to
make wise choices comprehends the
consequences of contemplated courses of
action minimum grade majority of
judgments are measured circumspect
relevant and correct minimum middle
grade decisions are constant or scar
consistent and uniformly correct
tempered by consideration of their
consequences able to identify isolate
and assess relevant factors in the
decision making process opinions sought
by others subordinates personally
personal interest in favor of
impartiality and the high end decisions
reflect exceptional exceptional insight
and wisdom beyond this Marines
experience counsel sought by all often
an arbiter consistent superior judgment
inspires the confidence of seniors
so that's how you get graded on
intellect and wisdom and actually the
last thing that they grade you on is
they actually grade you on how well you
evaluate your other Marines
the extent to which this officer serving
as a reported official conducted or
required others to conduct accurate
uninflated and timely evaluations this
is the last thing you'll be graded on
and they go through your the low end is
like you did a good job the high end is
you do an outstanding job but their
grading you on how well you grade and
then you get to the last page which
where this is where you have the
christmas-tree the Eagle Globe and
Anchor christmas-tree comparative
assessment provide a comparative
assessment of potential by placing an X
in the appropriate box in marking the
comparison consider all the Marines of
this grade whose professional abilities
are known to you personally and then you
go through that tree the unqualified
unsatisfactory a qualified marine one of
the many highly qualified professionals
who form the majority of this grade one
of the few exceptionally qualified
Marines and then you get to the top the
singular marine at the top who is the
eminently qualified marine the eminently
qualified marine and that's what I think
makes this makes this interesting is to
to consider that statement eminently
qualified and think about where you're
at
and you you're not a top I'm not a top
none of us are at the top but who can be
but what are we striving to be what are
we striving to be are we striving to be
the most eminently qualified human being
that we can be do you even know what
that means you have those thoughts in
your head I'm guessing you don't I
barely do I know I've had vague thoughts
I know I had definitions that floated
around my head of what I was trying to
be what I'm trying to be today but why
aren't those solid why aren't they I was
I was thinking about this I was talking
to Dave Burke good deal yeah good deal
Dave and I was like hey we need to build
this they're basically an evaluation
system for humans to become eminently
qualified as a human what does that look
like
not only to graved yourself but to
actually know what you are trying to be
so Dave and I'll work on that so stand
by to get some and until until we do get
that out then think about think about
are there areas that you know what the
goal is that you're walking around
thinking that you deserve a 5.0 but you
really actually
you really actually deserve to I know I
do that yes right yes um I'm thinking
I'm good I'm walking around I'm thinking
I'm running everything right I'm
thinking I'm thinking I come correct you
yes but the reality is I don't yeah and
and the reality is you have that little
moving goalpost in your head you move it
around a little bit right you give
yourself a little bit more slack one day
then you tighten it up cuz you're
feeling good the next day then you slack
it off a little bit more but as far as
you're concerned that's a 500 right
you're there you're in there and the
reality is I don't measure up the way I
should be measuring up on a daily basis
on an hourly basis who's grading me
who's lying to me you know who is me
yeah me but until we clarify what the
aim is what the goal is and what those
standards are how am I supposed to hold
myself accountable to those standards
when they don't even exist so I'm gonna
make them exist I'm gonna put them in
I'm gonna put them on paper we're going
to come up with that eminently qualified
human being what that looks like because
we all got all got ideas floating around
up there yeah well I'm gonna bring it
bring it
I'm gonna apply that put it into action
put it into action right are we doing
everything that we could be doing
everything that we should be doing are
we cutting corners are we slacking off
we'd given ourselves a 5.0 when we
should be at best cracking a - daily how
much are we leaving on the table every
day that's a question for you right how
much are we leaving on the table how
much you saying I you know what I can
sleeve that there it's a fine how much
how many things just do you accept this
collateral damage like something goes
wrong like one thing goes wrong so
there's just collateral damage other
things are just gonna fall by the wait
and you're good with it yeah you're good
with it something you you you know yeah
I hurt my knee
I'll go guess what I'm gonna eat a
doughnut right is that
we're at yeah is that what we're at or
is there collateral damage Oh work was
hard therefore I'm gonna you know treat
my family not gonna not gonna have a
good family quality time tonight
collateral damage because they what do
you expect from me Yeah right where's
the collateral damage why are we
allowing this collateral damage well
part of the reason I'm telling you that
we allow this collateral damage is
because we're not effectively grading
ourselves and even worse than that we
don't even know what standards we're
trying to achieve no one's even told us
the minimum standard oh okay so why is
your life going marginal right now why
are you doing okay why am i doing okay
right now well it's because I have some
vague idea I kind of know I'm heading in
the right general direction that's not
good enough to get maximum it's not good
enough to be eminently qualified it does
doesn't work you have to step it up you
have to you have to have the unmitigated
daily discipline in all things and
that's hard it's hard for one day
never mind every single day so I'm gonna
make this evaluation Dave and I are
gonna make it I'll get it out to y'all
and until then and I'll try and get it
turned around as quick as possible at
least some kind of a what is it called
an early version a beta test is that
what it's called sure I think no like
the technology right right yeah sure
Nate it will get a beta test we'll try
and get something out there quick and
until then start looking at yourself as
usual your strengths and your weaknesses
and start trying to see where you can
improve start moving towards the goal of
becoming the eminently qualified human
being where we're heading
and I think that is all I've got for
tonight so
echo Charles we got well I got I know
I'm not worth trying to step up yep we
have thoughts well yeah so you and you
actually mentioned it in like right
there at the end there where all these
little Evo little but all these
evaluations are like you know you do
this consistently and all the stuff it's
so there's two kind of parts to that
when I was thinking you you have to do
all these good things right to be the
minimum or to be the you know you you
can't even really be in the group if
you're not in the minimum right but you
gotta do those things every day like you
have to essentially be known for these
things yes so so how we get jammed up I
think when we when we are conscious of
like how good am i doing in XYZ area of
my life or whatever and if it's
something that you're working on a lot
of times we don't get the accurate
evaluation to ourselves because we'll do
we'll do it really good one day and
we'll do it really good two days I don't
playing dang I'm pretty good at this so
I'm gonna go ahead and give myself like
four or whatever but meanwhile you only
did it twice me know you know in the
whole week you did it twice you're so
happy because it's this big change
because you usually do it zero times
yeah so you're like hey I got this you
your minimum bar was set so low yeah you
think you're crushing it oh yeah Anubis
because in your mind you kind of are
comparatively spirit of looking is it
like if you have a standard and stuff
then you can act more accurately but we
don't have standard so in your mind it
feels like oh I got this I got I like
them I'm a for now you know I used to be
one I'm a for now so meanwhile you're
not a four you're actually still a 1
yeah really really yeah do you think
you're you and there's also there's also
this there's also and I I talked to Dave
about this a little bit there's a
there's a short term great and there's a
long term great cuz check this out let's
say you let's say you never worked out
before and you've been watching video
games and eating Donuts and and just you
know in bad physical shape yeah your
grade your overall grade for physical
fitness is whatever it's a 1.0 so low
it's the lowest it can go
but daily if you get up okay look look I
can only run one mile and it's gonna
take me 20 minutes 22 minutes mm-hmm I'm
gonna do it and then I'm gonna do as
many pushups as I can which is 23 by the
way if I did a one-mile run in 22
minutes and did 23 push-ups that would I
would get a 1.0 for the day but this
individual that's been on the couch
didn't living a sedentary lifestyle
if he does that guess what he's gonna
get him he's gonna get a high grades get
a 4.8 for the day hmm so then he's
leading himself in the right direction
yeah so not only is that not only do you
have to this is one of the problems in
it and again this is something I told
Dave I'm like listen a once a biannual
twice a year every six months you're
getting a grade that doesn't help you
what you need to look at yourself every
day you need to look at yourself every
day and say did I truly live this way
live the way I should be living today
and then those standards need to be
clear and then you need to apply them to
your life yeah I might even say like the
the that example you just gave so the
guy who's sitting on the couch all the
time or whatever or every day and now
he's doing he's working out every day
but his physical fitness standard
technically still law still very I don't
know maybe another area of evaluation is
like you know improvement or you know
how you say or back when you're young
you know they give you that Most
Improved kind of thing yeah maybe that
could be part of it I think it will be
covered by the daily track the daily
track like okay you got a you got a 4.0
today what's your average right now my
average for the last mile running
average for 30 days is I'm hitting a 3.9
physical-fitness that means I'm doing
something every day I'm pushing the
envelope I'm improving now my overall
score is moved from a 1 to a 1.2 yeah
because I I'm in a little bit better
shape but it's still not where it needs
to be yeah guess what that can crush
some people right
if someone
1.2 I'm never gonna improve that sucks
and then three months no guess what
would you get today what'd you do today
same thing opposite right the opposite
can happen where someone thinks well I
did something I did something today so
I'm good man
no no and the other collateral damages I
did good physical fitness today so I'm
gonna take tomorrow off or I'm gonna eat
a you know a crappy meal yeah I'm gonna
get that Pizza together
Yeah right we don't want that we and
when I say we I mean me yeah in that why
is that because we've we've we've
created this this this pliable standard
in our head that we move around based on
our little feelings you but but this
does this won't allow for it you need to
keep yourself in check yeah you need to
keep yourself in check at all times and
the reason you need to keep your check
yourself in check at all times you need
to impose discipline on your life
because you will end up in a better
situation that you will end up in a
better situation you want to put more
freedom is where you're gonna end up you
know people you talk about regret right
oh you go talk to people when they're
when they're dying on their deathbed and
they're gonna they're gonna regret
things they didn't do there's nothing I
can imagine you're gonna regret more
than when you look back at your life and
said I didn't achieve what I could have
achieved yeah and there's only one way
to maximize your achievement and that's
the daily discipline daily disciplined
and again when we're talking about
achievement what are we talking about
I'm not just talking about I've worked
more than you I made more money than you
I produced more I sold more cars and
that's not what I'm talking about I'm
talking about what what is your what is
your achievement yeah what is that
you're trying to do
I spent a bunch of time with my family
and raised two great kids okay that's
what you want to do put that on paper so
you know what that looks like hmm maybe
there is a financial there is should be
a financial aspect to it because you
need to pay you need to have a roof over
your head you need to be able to feed
your kids so you certainly should
the job of vocation aspect to grading
yourself are you doing what you should
be doing Network because if you're
working hard at work guess what you're
gonna get promoted eventually or you're
gonna find out you can improve your
skills to a point where you be more
valuable and you can go find a different
job somewhere else so that's got to be
in there because if what we allow
ourselves to do is show up at work every
day and just do what we need to do to
get by guess what you're never leaving
that job you'd be doing that thing
forever
so it's physical fitness it's what
you're eating your fuel systems that
you're putting into your body it's the
family the the the effort what are you
doing to improve the skill sets of your
children what are you doing what are you
children are you spending 20 minutes
teaching them new vocabulary words so
that they can articulate better so they
can become a better leader when they get
older are you doing that is that a big
ask as a dad as a mom are you doing it
have you showed them how to escape a
guillotine have you maybe you should
because you can get caught in a
guillotine that's the street fight right
streetbike guillotines are coming you
know so have you does your kid know how
to escape a guillotine in a street fight
how much is it how long will it take you
got to teach them today that takes to 15
minutes but you got to drill it
you've got to drill it every day until
they kind of understand it so what have
you invested in your kids today what's
the minimum standard now you could think
to yourself well you know I got my kid
an iPad for Christmas that was an
awesome gift so I'm pretty much good to
go
yeah as a dad Yeah right does your kid
care about that iPad compared to you
fast forward three years where your kids
got an incredible vocabulary and can
defend guillotines right so how much
have you invested in your family so
these are the kind of things that we can
set a moving goal post where you can set
a moving goal post that says I
by a if you get your kid an iPad with
some apps on it you're a good dad that's
it moving goalposts hey you should hey
if you can get your kid an iPad and they
can get some educational stuff you feel
pretty good about a cool good job is
that a moving goalpost yes it is
yeah because what they really need to
know is have a better vocabulary what
they really need is interaction with you
as a human being so they can interact
with other human beings
in a more complete way that's what we're
doing so you got your physical you've
got your okay mental what are you how
much have you read today and I'm not
talking about reading somebody's
freaking Instagram post that doesn't
count
okay get negative credit for that you're
getting Dumber when you do that so what
what are you what are you doing how many
words did you learn today and by the way
this is brain maintenance too because if
you're not trying to learn new things
then your brain is deteriorating just
like your body will so you've got that
aspect what about your creative output
what have you done in that capacity
did you write us did you draw a picture
did you write a story did you come up
with a guitar riff that kind of rocks
[Music]
right because you may or may not have my
guess is you didn't know so how what
have you done that today and where and
by the way if you think oh I took a cool
picture for Instagram and I'm kind of
giving myself artistic credit for output
right there
you know No so and then you start
looking at all this stuff and you start
adding it together your time that you
invested in your work and your family
and your friends and you're trying to
try to teach your kids something and
you're trying to read something and all
of a sudden you look and you say well I
don't have much time and then you look
at yourself and say wait a second where
did my time go dick what grade do I get
today for time management yeah that's a
big one because did I spend time doing
things that I got negative value never
mind break even actually negative value
and we don't have a grading system we
don't know what we're aiming at we don't
know what the potential is because
that's what
about this you you read these
definitions the high-end the outstanding
the eminently qualified marine that is
an unachievable human yeah it's an
unachievable marine you will not be that
good you cannot hold all those
categories but let me tell you something
that is no reason to not aspire to
become the most eminently qualified
human being that you can become just
because it's an impossible path just
because it's a path with no end to it
just because you'll never reach the top
of the mountain ever you will not
you cannot hmm guess what that is no
reason to stop guess what
jujitsu you're gonna get tapped out you
there's always gonna be someone that
that can tap you out always 100% of the
time the best guys in the world get
tapped out yeah the best guys in the
world get tapped out buchecha ha ha drew
gracie buchecha is the best guy in the
world what happens he goes in ghee and
loses to hogr gracie tapped out
submitted why is that because somebody's
always and what happened Roger Gracie by
the way when he fought Tim Kennedy he
got beat down so there's always you're
never gonna get to the top of mountain
but that is not theirs and that is not a
reason to not to stop climbing just
because you're not gonna reach the top
of the mountain doesn't mean you stop
climbing no actually you climb harder
you see where you can get mmm but if you
don't know what you're climbing if you
don't understand the mountain if you
can't see the summit you don't know
where to climb and then you just look
around and gone well my muzzle just
slide down because it it it's it takes
physical and mental exertion to move up
the mountain and if I don't even know
where the top is I'm just gonna I can't
tell where I am I can't tell if I'm over
halfway up the mountain the quarter with
the mountain I can't tell from close to
the top bottom stop I can't tell so
there's enough reason for me just to sit
around and do nothing
break out the donuts no the K so the
leave started this was was with your
Navy experience his evaluations go and
okay so this is essentially what it
would it kind of translated to me what
it was in the Navy the one that you were
talking about was like everyone expected
to get the height the type the perfect
score right and now we start with the
standard and then the in the Marine
Corps one it's kind of the opposite well
no the Navy once started off when I
first got in the Navy basically everyone
was a 4.0 and then they changed it
because you need to force rank and I
don't know when the Marine Corps or if
they made that change but but they did
because that's the way it is now they're
force ranked for sure yeah okay so the
end the point it's just the two
different standards like common like
standards right we're you know one
because you get this in other places too
where it's like oh you know it's just
just your here's your quarterly
evaluation and I just put force you know
cuz I don't have any complaints about
you kind of theory it doesn't
necessarily reflect how dope you really
are it's just more how dope you could be
yes exactly right so it's just more of
like okay so the ceiling is pretty low
this is what it is by like a common like
perception as far as the standard goes
then you have the opposite where it's
like oh we all know no one's gonna get a
five like we all just know that so we're
we're just kind of doing the best we can
kind of thing and in that way is better
up for obvious reasons but at the end of
the day it's like when you say oh yeah
you can literally be like you're topping
out because as you get better and better
it's harder to get better than that
yes you know yes so if but you won't
even get to those upper levels if that
ceiling was so low and you're ripping
for is all day or all year or whatever
so man I used to UM he's the place came
Super Mario Brothers you're very that
super but I mean I don't think I've ever
played one single second of that
particular video game right thing bow
okay I played halo one time for about
three minutes with some of the guys that
was in my seal platoon and you know just
think once after you thought it was they
were really good at it they murdered me
a bunch of different ways yeah and then
I said well this is stupid it's a video
game I don't care who wants to go
grapple yeah
well that part is AI would say that
that's true but this the the point still
is consistent so Super Mario Brothers
it's okay so is Super Mario there's a
bunch of Mario Brothers
this one is Judaism well this one is
called Super Mario Brothers okay
original Nintendo Entertainment System
Larry I don't say nineteen wonders for
if I'm not okay that's cool so Super
Mario Brothers had four worlds sorry
eight worlds four levels each worlds of
32 levels and you have an opportunity at
various points in some levels to hit the
warp like the warp zone so you go down a
pipe in it skips like all these levels
right so you could see you could
essentially get through the game in
maybe like I don't know six or eight
levels okay if you warped right but if
you chose not to warp you would have to
go through all 32 levels so I used to be
able to go through all 32 levels never
die in one single time like I got really
really good at that you're for those
either just listening and not seeing
this on video Ecco look super proud of
that statement I mean I was a little bit
embarrassed for you it's cool anyway
okay there's no levels here's why that's
here's why that's significant though
it's for Super Mario Brothers girls
because you can easily pass the game
save the princess
by just warping and it's still real hard
but you could you know you only go
through a few levels compared to if you
go through all the levels voluntarily
so once you save the princess by warping
it's like cool now you got to go through
all the levels but if you can do that
without dying that's like that's super
high level right as far as Super Mario
Brothers goes so basically so can what's
your point so go back to the two
standards go back to the two standards
if you go for the stand it's like oh
yeah everyone gets a kind of a 4.0 kind
of thing that's like passing the passing
the game by warping it's true like man
you passed the game in one man damn
that's good that's good by any standard
really you know I can't complain about
that but you gotta open up standard a
little bit more go through all 32 levels
then without dying then you do it as
quick as you can't kind of thing and if
that standard can allows for all that
where you can't reach the top of the lid
like the standard isn't saving the
princess
standard is like something way greater
you seem saying so it allows you to get
better and be evaluated on that on that
elevation while still not like caffeine
out at a certain level he's ever saying
that's what you got to do as far as the
evaluation process goes okay bro I'm
telling you look to Super Mario but
there is this thing they discovered it
was like a glitch in the game where you
could like go to this one level and do
this thing with a turtle shell and keep
jumping on it and get like a thousand
men which is kind of a step backwards in
a way but that's just a side note
[Music]
dang okay
how much time have you spent playing
video games well as you know what you
could have done with your life yeah well
keep it guitar you could have played now
you know instruments you could have
mastered chess you could have spoken
another language instead you're over
here talking about how you did 32 levels
[Music]
this is a get you a really lower grade
well I'm up with the system your grade
is gonna be the low yes as far as the
cheap mints goes yes very low but as far
as an evaluation process did all that
translate it highly respect you did
jean-charles go to hangman did he kind
of yeah something there you go look at
that you finally got that respect you
wanna fight Mario I was in fifth grade
by the way so you know a little bit
different was that a humble brag like no
I think it was more of an aging thing
actually that wasn't a break at all cuz
in fifth grade you could have been
learning the language yes sir
yeah yeah we're doing pull-ups actually
what's doing pull-ups in fifth grade
that's legit yeah big-time
I thought check well okay less here's
the bottom line we are looking to step
up we are looking to to to become better
truly better so what do you got for us
how can you how can you help us get
better yes you stand the passo and
actually them that brings up a good
point because we're on the path
quote-unquote right you whatever all on
the path insane we're even saying we're
on the path straight up seining but like
what is the path though I mean sure
there's some things yeah you know we can
go through a jiu jitsu of course is part
of
but you don't have an evaluation kind of
standard this what you say it so yeah I
think that'll be how actually I'm really
looking forward to it yeah to be honest
with you yeah unless did you say yes
that's on the path here's okay so this
will help us prep that at the very least
prepare to be officially on the path and
be evaluated get Agee yeah
step one get Agee step one be get a rash
guard so where do we get our keys and
get our keys from origin origin Mein
Kampf s keys in the world factually
actually the new rift is that if it is
life Bree this is like when you put a
drift key on and then go back to your
old guy said it's before games
yeah non-starter you're gonna be mad at
your old guy you're gonna betray your
old geek you're gonna wonder why anyone
ever made
Aggie like they used to make them yeah
but then again then you're gonna then if
you choose you can revisit or you can
visit that video that Pete put out about
like you know it's like okay that's why
I didn't make it because what they went
through to make it yeah you know not
everyone's man yeah and as usual we are
standing on the shoulders of giants cuz
you always look at the way things have
evolved and you have to take those
iterative steps no one just thinks of
[Music]
the iPhone right right yeah somebody had
to make a bunch of other phones before
that oh yeah
and then even consider iPhone like right
now like what is the newest one
I don't know X or something something 10
X is the tenant you don't know me no
moves I guess I didn't know that at
first anyway the one in six years from
now is gonna make this x10 one you'd be
like oh it's old-school you know like
non evolved Neanderthal one that's
what's gonna feel like that's all that's
what your old D will feel like yes a non
involved Neanderthal geeky in the end
put on the rift yeah oh yeah so yeah you
can get you can get the gi's you can get
the rash guards you can get other
clothing you can also get supplements
which right now I am taking a ton of
joint warfarin yeah I heard money which
is not that big of a deal because let's
face it I'm walking here
round you know we're gonna be fine it's
not that prevalent want people to feel
like oh no what happened don't worry
everything is fine I did however up the
joint warfare and continue the krill oil
path but the joint warfare you can feel
it in there can feel it
like little micro nano robots and
they're repairing stuff now you have to
you know I know it happened with your
bicep but the last time I hurt my other
knee it was a disaster and this one is
already so anyhow get your joint warfare
I remember you well and I mean of course
I remember it because it was as recent
as today where you're like like
Wolverine right you lookin for us but
I'm like yeah well I dig it it's
probably the joint warfare but Yemen has
something to do with it but also there's
some there's definitely I definitely
have been blessed with some sort of a
ability to to heal up a little quicker
yeah thankthank usually knock on wood
that's what it seems like to me well
also we have milk which is additional
protein that happens to be delicious and
tastes like a dessert straight up the
way it goes with that also where your
kid milk same deal just for the kids
it's the same deal but they have
strawberry warrior kid milk which is
literally the best-tasting thing in the
world that has strawberry flavor because
mint is still my favorite and we do have
strawberry adult mulk coming out i t
need that and it is ridiculous what does
pee any testing evaluate now so I got
the little package in the mail
yeah and it's good it was so good so
yeah you can get that you know also
discipline and discipline go
so discipline if you are going to train
jiu-jitsu or you're going to do
something that's gonna require physical
output and at the same time mental
alertness so that's for me it was always
about hey pre mission
because when you're on a mission you
have to be physically ready and you have
to be mentally ready mm-hmm
you need both aspects and so that's why
we made discipline so you're ready for
those things and then also we have
disciplined go which is a which is a
capsule and the reason I made this is
because sometimes I'm going to speak or
I'm going to work with a company or I'm
gonna be in a boardroom all day and I
want to bring my a-game sure and I don't
want to have to drink a whole beverage
because I don't don't need it at that
time so I talked to Pete Brian we took
the the elements from discipline drink
put them into the capsule so that way if
you need to bring your a-game you can
get your discipline to go and that will
get you across the board
and so we'll a little bit of jock a
whitey yep so good in the original the
original tee that chuckle was in - yeah
just kind of like you know white tee
it's you know at first but now it's sort
of a staple it's like synonymous you
know chocolate white tee yeah it's just
it's synonymous with good taste it's
synonymous with 8,000 pound deadlift so
is that big Tim also the tee is
available at JA clothes store because
yes Jocko has a store which we already
know but that's a good place to visit to
stay in the game to represent while
you're in the game so if you want
t-shirts we got some lightweight hoodies
rolling rocking and rolling hmm
a lot of good evaluations on now on no
comment yet cuz you haven't put one on
yet because you haven't give me one a
lot well you know let's face it you kind
of deserve that one and it's also
changing minds of people who originally
Special Forces over here you know like
it's ops you know a the it's truth be
told they came out really good just even
like the fit the designs on the today's
had on the other night yes there it is
one of them there's - vert this - okay
right it's - you can
truckers hats yep patches on there bunch
of other stuff yeah bunch of cool so
yeah if you want chocolate or calm if
you want to represent while you're on
the path while you're being evaluated
that might be one of the evaluation uh
scenarios well your uniform come on
anyway yeah I guess if someone's just a
complete slob
yeah then maybe they do you need to step
it up yeah somebody yeah okay maybe
uniform will be judged but I doubt it
well okay well what be wearing a stinky
guy though oh yeah no that's that's a
uniform violation big-time yes sir oh
you didn't want to wash your geese oh
now we all have to suffer yeah yeah
you're gonna get punished
what if don't do that hey the the thrift
key the cool thing you can wash with
your normal clothes yeah because it's a
little dry it's it's not it's not like
when you put a regular key in and it's
like you threw a forty pound weight if
you're washing receiving oh yeah yeah
yeah and it takes nine hours to dry not
the riff the riff dries with your normal
like quick dried t-shirts just about
yeah did you see the video Pete head
when he's like going into the fibers
like he takes that fiber and it's like
breaking it and it's hard to break he
puts the two and you can't even break it
the whole key is that yeah yes good man
real good also subscribe to the podcast
if you haven't already that is for a
black of a better term it's important
it's something it's not nothing like to
subscribe versus if you didn't subscribe
yeah don't forget about also the warrior
kid podcast so this is one where your
kids can actually be educated this is
quality time with your kids you sit
there and listen to or your kid
podcaster instead of driving your car
and you're playing some lame music for
them or you're having them listen to
some dumb podcasts no haven't listened
to a warrior kid podcast they're gonna
learn from it you're gonna learn from it
just check it out it'll it'll help it
will help your kids it's got a text this
morning from a buddy who said Janna this
is going into the book
but he had a nephew who had been through
you know a rough time and ten years old
got him the warrior kid book boom
warrior kid hey that's that book
completely changed the trajectory of my
nephews life hmm
and that doesn't get much better than
that but the warrior kid podcast has the
same messages in a podcast format so
check that out and also while you're
there you can check out some of that
Irish Oaks ranch com where we have a
warrior kid that is making soap started
a business making soap on his farm from
goat milk and that goat milk will help
you stay clean stay clean my daughter
has a question for uncle Jake okay I'll
send it to him yeah yeah you don't take
you know we'll get that sorted might
also through youtube we have a YouTube
channel if you're interested in the
video version of this podcast and see
what Jocko looks like while he you know
gives it to you straight you know that's
where you go there's also some of echos
legit videos on there that he calls
legit videos well feels good about it
feels really good about him and just
like he feels good about getting through
32 levels yeah yeah sometimes and you'll
get psychological warfare if you need a
little if you everyone that looks for an
alarm it says oh really be great to have
an alarm for chuckle make an alarm
that's the alarm psychological warfare
it's on iTunes Google Play mp3 platforms
and not not only will it wake you up in
the morning but if you're having a
moment of weakness because you want to
eat a donut mmm this will 100% effective
stop you from eating a donut press play
psychological warfare check it out also
flipside canvases my brother Dakota
Meyer you heard him on this podcast
number 115 if you haven't listened that
podcast just go listen to it give
yourself about four hours because it's
long and it's heavy but he's got a
company where he's putting images on to
various forms of canvas of nylon or what
is it vinyl vinyl and you can take these
things and that way these are kind of
things you can put up in your house
where you look at it and you get that
little extra message to go get some
or that all your excuses are lies or
that things are good or that discipline
equals freedom so check it out flipside
canvas dot-com support my brother Dakota
Meyer some really good stuff on there
also if you're looking to expand your
your workout horizons go to on it comm
slash Jocko they got some good workout
gear on there a lot of good info a lot
of good stuff on there overall it's like
to to optimize your whole situation well
you got really good stuff on there on it
calm /co some books I just talked about
way the warrior kid that's a one that's
book one the next book same series
called marks mission and then there's
the third book in the series which is
called way the warrior kid where there's
a will so that is now live for pre-order
at this time if you want it order it now
that way I can print enough copies for
everyone
that's called the big pre-order that I
used to make fun of my publisher but
guess who the publisher is now me so I
have to know how many to print so if you
want it order it now and it's gonna come
out May 28th so there you go also we
have Mikey and the Dragons this is a
book to help kids figure out how to
overcome fear sure your kids could lead
read some book where you could read some
book to your little kid that's about
things that don't matter in the world or
you could read them a book it helps them
actually learn how to overcome their
fears that's Mikey and the dragons great
story awesome art yes the discipline
equals freedom Field Manual give the
gift of discipline you know that's
that's all there is to say hmm it's the
book that's gonna show people that you
it's gonna show people the path hmm if
you want that on audio form then that's
not on audible it's on iTunes Amazon
music Google Play and other mp3
platforms then you got extreme ownership
which I wrote with my brother
Lafe babban where we took the leadership
lessons we learned on the battlefield
and explained how those can be applied
to your business in life and one of
those lessons in that book is called the
dichotomy leadership
the dichotomy of leadership seemed to be
as we continue to work with businesses
companies leaders around the world we
found that the biggest problem that they
had was balancing the dichotomy of
leadership and when you can't balance
the dichotomy of leadership the multiple
dichotomies of leadership when you can't
balance them they derail your whole team
so get extreme ownership and get
yourself the dichotomy of leadership so
that you can understand how to truly
apply these things effectively a chillon
front that's my leadership consultancy
and what we do is solve problems through
leadership we have an outstanding team
of outstanding guys Lafe Babb and JP
Danelle Dave Burke Mike Cochran
we're sorry Flynn Cochran Mike Cirelli
Mike bimah and now Jason Gardner if you
need help at your company with any
problem because every problem that you
have in your business is a leadership
problem that's what we do we solve
problems through leadership Ashlin front
comm we have the muster coming up
Chicago
23rd 24th we haven't pulled this
sold-out switch yet but we're going to
it's almost sold out September 19th and
20th that's that's May 23rd and 24th in
Chicago September 19th and 20th in
Denver and then December 4th and 5th and
Sydney extreme ownership calm if you
want to register do it quickly because
all of them are going to sell out
EF online this is for those either can't
make it to a muster or you can't bring
your whole company to a muster because
it's expensive that's why we made EF
online this is online interactive
leadership training it's me and it's
everyone on the Echelon front team
training leadership through technology
it's it's available direct-to-consumer
if you're just one person you want to
get in the game or you've got a company
you can get it through enterprise but if
you want to check it out go to EF
online.com and of course on top of that
we have EF overwatch where we're taking
leaders proven leaders from spec ops and
from combat aviation putting them
placing them into companies in the
civilian sector
don't always hire someone based just
because they have experience in a field
actually hire them for their leadership
capability because it is a lot easier to
teach someone an industry than it is to
teach someone leadership so get yourself
a qualified proven leader go to EF
overwatch comm if that's what you need
and if you want to hang out with us a
little bit more because you're just not
satisfied with 500 hours of us on this
podcast well then we are on the
interwebs we are on Twitter we on
Instagram and of course we are on that
bow echo is that echo Charles and I am
at Jocko willing and thanks to all the
people that make this podcast possible
and by that I mean not some big
corporate sponsor by that I mean our
police our military our law enforcement
our firefighters paramedics EMTs
dispatchers correctional officers Border
Patrol and yes Secret Service all you
first responders all you and uniform
your service and your sacrifice allow us
to live to live a life of liberty and
the pursuit of happiness which is what
we're doing here and everyone else out
there
check yourself evaluate yourself
honestly are you doing what you can do
to be better are you working as hard as
you can and that just doesn't mean work
as in your vocation or your job are you
working to be a better father or mother
or daughter or son are you maximizing
opportunities and again not just
professional opportunities but
opportunities to help someone to teach
someone to coach someone to make someone
else better are you maximizing the
opportunities to spend time with your
family to strengthen the relationships
you have
are you maximizing the opportunities to
make the members of your family better
are you every day doing everything you
can to live the most eminently worthy
life you can live ask yourself those
questions and when you realize that you
fall short that we all fall short when
you realize that then get yourself on
the path to correct those shortfalls by
going out there and getting after it and
until next time this is echo and Jocko
out